we're going to try out a little
mathematical trick with you today Brady
it's nothing special I mean it's nothing
new but we'll try it out I'm going to
ask you to pick a number between 1 and
30 don't say it out loud but pick a
number between 1 and 30 have you done
that ok
and we'll pull it on the string yes yeah
great so we put it on the screen and
guys at home can play along ok so we're
going to use Brady's number I don't know
what his number is at the moment but I'm
going to hold up these cards and they
have numbers on them of course if you
see your number let me know so yes
and if you don't see your number say no
say pass something like that ok so let
me know yes yes do you see on them below
no do you see your number no no do you
see your number no no do you see your
number yes yes do you see your number
yes yes are we back at the beginning yes
ok so in that case we're back at the
beginning I can stop so I should know
that your number was 17 is that right
yes yes right so now how did we do that
it is an old trick but if you haven't
seen it before what you do is I know
which which was Brady's number because I
was adding up the numbers in the top
left corner and I look at the top left
corners I actually do it this way by
spread out the cards do you all have
different numbers on them but look at
the top left corner now if you notice
the top left corner all powers of 2
starting from 1 their powers of 2 so 1 2
4 8 and 16 the 1 is a power 2 it's 2 to
the power 0 I knew what Brady's number
was going to be because I added on these
left numbers for each one he said yes
four so Brady said yes to this one the
red one and he said yes to this one the
blue one and he said no to the others
and I knew that I could add those two
numbers together the 1 and the 16 and he
added 3
his secret number now the point is every
number can be written as a sum of powers
of two that's the point so whatever
number you pick these have been designed
so that if you add up the powers of two
it will give you your secret number let
me show you what I mean
if I write down the powers of two so
that does start with a one though I am
going to write it right to left so 2 4 8
16 second and we pick a number like
Idaho 20 now which of these do I need to
use to make 20 which do I need to add on
and we use the 16 and the 4 I've written
a 1 here to indicate I'm using the 16
and the 4 don't use the rest I'm going
to write a 0 to show that don't use the
back now this is binary this is the
famous binary which computers use is to
count I'm going to give you a twist to
this I'm going to show you a new way to
do this trick a less well-known way to
do this trick let's try it up
I've got new set of cards here this is a
little s a well-known version of the
trick same trick I shall we do it in the
same way all right so here's my cards
again you're going to pick a number
cause keep it to yourself but if you can
put it on the screen everyone can play
we've done that ok right so hopefully
we'll do this again ok tell me yes and
no when you have your number okay yes
No so I know for that one no no for that
one no no for that one no no for that
one yes yes for that one no no for that
one no no for that one did you pick 8
yes
you picked 8 he picked this one on his
own okay now did you notice what the top
left numbers were this time they weren't
the powers of 2 this time did you notice
what they were they were Fibonacci
numbers these icons tell you that we can
do the same trick using Fibonacci
numbers what I mean is we can write
every
as a sum of Fibonacci numbers as well
like we did with binary let me try it
out so let's write out the Fibonacci
numbers there's one there's two there is
three and there's eight no this five get
that right James
and then there's eight then there's 13
and 21 so I go up to 21 there we go
right now let's pick a number
what shall we pick 19 so I'm gonna pick
the number 19 what do I need to make 19
let's use the 13 because that's quite
big number and while 6 now so a 5 and a
1 so I've written ones that indicate
what to use I'm going to write zeros
everywhere else and again it looks like
a binary sum it looks like my binary
it's a binary sum it uses ones and zeros
but this time the ones indicate which
Fibonacci number to add together using
this idea you can make any number you
want using Fibonacci numbers and if you
don't use consecutive Fibonacci numbers
so here I use the 5 now I could have
used instead of 5 I could have done 2 &
3 well if I don't use 4 consecutive ones
its unique so there's only one way to do
this so you can do this trick with
Fibonacci but now I'm going to add an
extra twist to this because although I
don't have the cards for you I'm afraid
you can do this trick again with prime
numbers every number can be written as a
sum of prime numbers as well
so I'll show you how I made those cards
then all right and then and then
everyone can make them because you can
make them at home so I'll use the powers
of two cards I'll show you how to make
them and then if you learn this you can
make your Fibonacci ones as well I
started with the powers of two in the
top left corner now I said okay I've got
one I've got two three well to make
three it has to be on this card and on
this card because those numbers add up
to three so you write down your three
like that four is here great five well
how do I make five one and four so I
have to write the five on the one and
the four card then the six well it's
four and two
so I should write the 6 here and here so
let's go back to Brady's 17 as we know
that 17 is well think about the powers
of 2 16 plus 1 would do it and that's
why I wrote 17 here on the 16 card when
I wrote 17 here on the 1 card
that's how I made them now the fact that
you can do it with Fibonacci numbers is
not obvious it's called Zeckendorf
theorem which crime cool name but it's
actually missed name the first guy
coming up came up with this was called
let cuca curve and that was his name
that's fun everyone can enjoy let kakuka
the prime version of it is also another
surprise and altogether if you want to
know how to do it in general
it's called Brown's criterion and these
aren't the only sequences for which this
works for but they're pretty cool bonds